i'm on tick-tock came at me very very  quickly clearly from nothing to  people knowing who i am yep and with  that is a lot of hate and i was just  wondering like from in school to  comments like what's the best way to  deal with that think about how much it  would suck to be in a place in your life  where you are so hurting inside that you  want to drag somebody else down  compassion and empathy and everyone's  like [ __ ] haters you know like like  delete it i've actually only seen it one  way from the first day in 2006 to now i  actually feel warmth towards the people  that hate me the most i mean it i've  been taking hate for a decade if  somebody at school or in the comments is  taking the time to watch your videos and  tell you that you're ugly you suck  you're stupid they're in a very bad  place